you know if you had to pick who you
thought was going to win tonight who do
you think is going to 100 my girl
marianne i call her my little one i love
her you know marianne is somebody that
feels all the feels and when you watch
her you relate you connect uh there was
a challenge she did where she was
running and she had to jump off this
really really high beam and she screamed
and just let out this like crazy like ah
and i laughed and i know everyone had
that because of course you're gonna
scream when you're jumping from a
60-foot tower so um i definitely
definitely think it's marianne's gonna
take it tonight
so i i feel like that answers my
question with who has impressed you the
most this season she absolutely has
impressed me the most you know marianne
reminds me a lot of myself i think that
a lot of people underestimate her and i
think that's their biggest mistake
because she's going to sneak attack from
behind and get that million dollars
and she does she'll be the second
canadian in a row what do you think it
is about like canadians that's just
apparently like get they get on the show
and then they start winning i mean
canadians are graded you know we we
haven't let them do it for this long so
they're like we're going to make our
mark not only that but if she does win
marianne will be the second black woman
to win survivor which is something that
i wasn't able to do
i it makes me so emotional just thinking
about it and i really do hope that
happens for her tonight i do do you feel
like that will encourage more black
women and just women of color in general
to go out and audition absolutely you
know my family always says survivor is
some white people stuff i'm like no it's
not i did last 38 out of 39 days in the
jungle 2-2 um but absolutely i think you
know and not just black women we see
omar who is muslim we have high we have
so much representation and to be able to
see that and have somebody like a child
like oh my gosh they look like me or
they sound like me or they do the same
thing as me or they're weird like me um
just to have that representation is so
important for all different categories
of people
now
uh if you were missed if i didn't
mention the soul survivor alliance i
mean
if you could tell yourself when you guys
were first sort of starting this what
you guys would be able to achieve at
this point like what would you say to
yourself
um that anything is possible and
survivors are resilient if you want
something to happen you can make it
happen and it's so nice when you have a
network and something that you love that
is going to stand behind you and support
that and support who you are because for
so long especially we as black
just so to people something like
survivor that you idolize you look up to
to actually hear you and support you and
want to highlight you and give you
visibility
that's immeasurable it's it i mean it's
crazy to even think about you know and
and i just feel heard and i feel seen
and i want to thank them i love jeff he
knows that
um you know and obviously though like
you know work still isn't done what
would you like to see not just on
survivor but cvs reality shows in
general i just want to see every single
type of person walk of life represented
you know i want to see more lgbtq plus
on on the show i want to see just all
different varieties types of people it
doesn't have to be the same archetype
every single time that's boring who
wants to watch that anyway you know
survivor is the show that keeps on
giving it keeps evolving it keeps
growing and i think as long as they
continue to do that they'll continue to
be the number one reality show on
television
so you know i feel like i have to ask
for the fans could you ever see yourself
going back on survivor girl give me that
mic yes i'm going jeff call me okay i'm
ready to go i want my million um you
know survivor is one of those things
that when you do it you feel like you
can do anything in the world and for me
a girl who's a barbie girl likes her
makeup to know that i can survive
outside do my own thing kick take names
uh yeah i i'm on the next flight out
and we haven't had a in person finale
carpet in a long time why was it so
important for you guys to come together
tonight with all the other former
contestants you know for me it's really
about connecting the fans with the show
and i think like you see these people
you see these reality stars that you
like but you don't feel like you get you
get to be connected to them and i think
that's what was so fun about the live
shows and we're missing that not to say
anything but you might see some people
from 42 here tonight um so we wanted to
show up and show up for them you know pg
who played a little while back she threw
my finale party and it meant so much to
me so we just wanted to give them a
proper send off let them know we're here
for them we love them and to thank them
for an amazing amazing season
you